[Musique]
pour répondre à la demande de ceux de
nos téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas eu la
chance de suivre notre feuilleton
cosmique
depuis le début nous allons résumé la
situation
nous avons à droite du ciel la planète
plate dgipi quand elle était trop lourde
d'un côté le punch quentin libye allait
d'un côté il fallait et qu'il y en est
un autre qui avec de l'autre côté à
gauche du ciel nous avons la planète à
shadoks qu'elle n'était pas pratique non
plus elle avait tendance à tomber par le
bas il y avait d'une part des châteaux
qu'ordinaire avec des pâtes en bas
n'était pas excessivement intelligent et
il y avait d'autre part des shadoks
spéciaux avec des pâtes en eau
il n'était d'ailleurs pas plus
intelligente pour ça mais il s'il
n'avait pas été là il n'y aurait rien eu
pour soutenir la planète dans l'espace
et et leur est complètement tombé mais
de ses chats doc là il n'y en avait pas
partout et là où il en manquait ça ça
fait c'est et les shadoks eux aussi
voulaient aller sur la terre leur fusée
n'était pas prêt très bon point mais il
avait calculé qu'elle avait quand même
une chance sur un million de marché et
qu'il se dépêchait de bien rater les
999 999 premier essai pour être sûr que
le millionième marche avec ce genre de
raisonnement typiquement shadoks les
pauvres n'était pas prêt du parti en
tout cas pas comme ça
[Musique]